facciamo una premessa allora io non
seguo una mazza di youtube ma proprio
niente
trovo difficile fare dei quiz di altra
gente però anzi sicuramente ne sapete
meglio però registriamo lo tanto favore
di ultime qui su mike scioscia su sorin
cameron dallas e qui su youtube italia
camerun dallas va bene dov'è quello capi
iscritti in italia specie di mettere gli
altri c'era anche un'altra pagina
scusate aspettato dalla cioè amedeo
preziosi a wed george deve incazzare
alla pagina successiva
diamo dove mi avete gabbo di square ed
esterni surreal povera anima mette bizet
e la ras al sito squallido ditelo subito
pagina successiva
dredd ipantellas si liscia
niente ragazzi non sono più di
importanza io non mi si caga più di
pezza nessuno allora ciò che è bello
vicino a sofia viscardi beh facciamo
prima il quiz su di me è giusto perché
io ne so su di me almeno quello per
iniziare proprio a scaldarsi non puoi
trovare molte informazioni nei due tinte
al santissimo dj leggendo libri sotto le
cuffie poi acquistarlo per un prezzo
scontatissimo che forse non è così
squallido come sito in che anno è nato
risposta 190 c dai scaldiamo c per
quello che stava facciamo giusto come si
chiama su primocanale sale gaming alcuni
giochi non ha mai giocato
angri mario esiste in che hanno aperto
su primocanale 2011 come si chiama il
programma televisivo che partecipazione
sociale ei tic hanno raggiunto amia gli
scritti 2014 dove è nato felice nava
torino sto sbagliando la mia domanda è
stato più netto per interior dice regole
button qualità anas per marzia l'ha
preso prima vittoria queste sarebbe
falsa ma la metto vera perché so che tu
hai messo vero quali tra questi non è un
prodotto sponsorizzato da fa vj zaino
per la scuola è io c'ho il mio zaino 15
album di figurine quello che avevo fatto
tipo quattro anni fa pastelli a cera non
l'ho mai fatto buoni buoni della spesa
io non ho mai fatto né nei pastelli a
cera nei buoni della spesa zio dovrei
mettere tutte e due con quali gruppo di
youtube collabora fra vj non è vero mi
sono tutti in culo però
scherzate mail perché ipantellas sono un
duo non fatte 7 su 10 in un mio quiz per
fare la patente sono 40 domande ne puoi
sbagliare al massimo quattro pensa che
speranze di riuscire in quei quiz che
hanno aperto il suo primo canale 2011
risposte corrette 2012 no ignorante
maledetto era 2011 era giusto vice è
stato il primo youtuber italiano a
ricevere il golden ma la ragazza di pd
pare averlo preso prima che è italiana
ma fa video in inglese quindi era una
domanda trabocchetto questa ci sta quale
tra questi non è un prodotto
sponsorizzato da fa vj buoni della spesa
ho messo era sbagliato pastelli a cera
quindi io secondo te ho sponsorizzato
dei buoni della spesa perché la gente va
a far la spesa che targata fa vj la
gente non sbagliata una sola io l'ho
sbagliate 3 io non smetto nessuna 2
sbagliate io sono io non sbagliate 3
questa è la pesca al darci andiamo a
fare i quiz degli altri adesso allora
quiz migliori youtuber italiani vai
proviamo a fare questo i migliori
youtuber in italia risposta 1 quale di
questi a meno di 500 mila iscritti
mi è arrivato un messaggio grazie a dio
mi ha salvato dalla figura di cacca nel
lago
non lo so basta la godo
non lo so ragazzi quali youtube era
guadagnato di più nell'ultimo mese credo
io perché sono più famoso ti farà un
programma televisivo su sky penso step
di perché in socialfake non lo so chi ha
giocato nello stadio olimpico a roma su
realtà ore nota neanche cos'è una balla
ciò che è un'idea avrò chi ha il secondo
canale con più iscritti 2 su server dead
2 su server hanno 820 canali per il
nostro credo yotobi credo io toby vai
fine la zecca the 3 su 5 poi a youtube
lavorato di più fa vigili si mostra
sbagliata non sono io
prendiamo una persona che non conosco
manco per sbaglio cioè sono praticamente
tutte quiz me contro te io li conosco
tantissimo e me contro tehreek anno è
nata sofia noto se non lo so
93 incanalato luigi bea mi ha scoperto
rischiavano luigi e sofia 93 92
mica è stato loro primo no 91 ci ripensa
qual è stato proprio video su youtube
quale è stato loro quale quale con
l'apostrofo cristo qual è il loro video
più visto spingo e piscina ma scritto un
libro che strumento suonava luigi mi
sembra proprio un tipo da piana da
chitarra in casa si sono fidanzati
penso 2012 sono che hanno fatto video
dopo che si sono fidanzati non lo so ora
ga fine 2 su 10 sono un grande fan
cosa ho azzeccato palermo sono nati lì
chitarra visto che era un tipo da
chitarra ho detto io sono orgoglioso di
me stesso
facciamo il quiz su greta menkes non so
niente greta non si sa dove sei finita
ma se guardi questo video sappi che mi
ci metto d'impegno cannonata pam quali
oggetti colleziona non lo so lo so lega
quali di questa affermazione è vera ha
doppiato un film ha intervistato fa vj
ha doppiato un film con me l'ha fatto
tra cui si chiama sul primo canale
myblog con quali youtube l'inglese ha
fatto una challenge chiesa e di quel
ragazzo alla fatto una cover con chef
ora mi sto sparando tutto con quali di
questi youtuber non ha mai fatto una
challenge de carli come i nomi di corona
che sarah aveva fatta con messico ha
fatto la questa greta e mi sta
insultando sport praticava nuoto che
sono solo si è fatto un servizio papà
francesco
spero di sì fine sette su dieci non mi
aspettavo di meglio va bene basta non
condividiamo starò nuovo quiz su greta
menchic è bello che viviamo su twitter
sarà la prima cosa mi rispondono i miei
twitter abilmente con immagini di che
hip hop dalla capitale nuovo qui
segretaria nichi p domande in questo
tweet che nei compiti di scuola dei
ragazzi possiamo concludere quali ray
che è abbastanza perché ho fatto delle
cose che avrei preferito non fare prove
però di aver azzeccato le domande sui
vostri youtube preferiti corrotto sul
sottoscritto anzi no sul sottoscritto
non le ho cercate purtroppo farò sapere
quando farò la patente quanti errori
farò come al solito ragazzi se vi è
piaciuto sul momento mi piace anche i
soci hanno vinto da iniziare se non
siete presi rischiate linee ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo vi do ragazza
[Musica]